[Music]
you know you can tell when you're the
world's greatest spy star sterling Lance
sterling
everyone knows the name
[Music]
don't take the law so hard I mean you
got to meet lance sterling
thank you thank you go back to work
fred-bag Chris - is too much it's
probably the right amount still go back
[Music]
home it is gonna change spying forever
it's called biodynamic concealment
imagine if I can make you wait for it
drumroll please disappear disappear
disappear why are you saying it like
that or effect that next generation
concealment you wouldn't happen to have
it on hand would you
I do happen to have it in hand show it
to me sure um what can I help you a
drink I got water drinkable music ready
mm-hmm
we had a drink Wow diet stuff has a
weird aftertaste
what's the tech
it worked subject appears disoriented
what did you do hey Lance look at me
look at you
I can't not look at you Walter I can see
my butt and your face at the same time
pigeons are everywhere nobody notices
them up girl
it's the most perfect form of I could
take it better unburden me right now
that's it I'm the pilot I'm Bert I'm
raising my voice I probably shouldn't be
raising my voice at you I need you to
unburnt me Walter you booted yourself
[Music]